TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your quick update
about the coolest developer
news from Google
in the last week.
The third annual Android
Security Year in Review
is now available.
It's a comprehensive
look at our work
to protect more than 1.4 billion
Android users and their data.
Take a look at the post
for a highlights, a video,
and a link to the full report.
The first developer preview
of Android O is now available.
Android O introduces a number
of new features and APIs
to use in your apps, including
background limits, notification
channels, autofill
APIs, and more.
Details and links
are on the post.
Also now available is the latest
version of the Android Native
Development Kit,
Android NDK r14.
Updates are detailed
on the post.
Chrome 58 beta is out.
Updates include
IndexedDB 2.0 standard,
now fully supported,
and improvement
to I-frame navigation,
immersive full screen for PWA's,
and more.
Screen shots and
links are on the post.
We recently launched
Cloud Functions
for Firebase, which is a
great solution for running
back-end code for
your Firebase app.
These functions can be
triggered on certain events,
as well as scheduled.
To get started scheduling
jobs with Cloud functions
for Firebase,
check out the post.
Remember, sharing is caring.
I'm with Timothy Jordan,
and I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks for
watching this week's episode
of The Dev Show.
If you enjoyed this episode,
you should do several things.
One you should share with all
your friends and colleagues.
Two, you should subscribe
to this channel,
because it's super awesome.
And three, maybe you want to see
some of our previous episodes.